hello everyone and welcome back to the
kappa blanka saga we are finished with
the Sabourin cup also played in the Sun
feature book in 1913 we are now in 1914
this is one of the one of the strongest
tournaments played up until that point
and we're just gonna show the
contestants so you get a bit of a better
idea of what the tournament is is about
in this game our names of which faces
host a row kappa blanka
and names of each with the white pieces
but this is the the lineup so like we
said we will have emmanuel asked for
joining us in this tournament we have
josé raúl capablanca Alexander the
Aegean Ziggler Tariq frame James
Marshall Aussie Bernstein a keyboard
moonshine arrow names which Joseph Henry
Blackburn the Black Death
Darwin offs Quillan Isidore Ginsburg and
it's a similar lineup
if you remember from the 1911 census the
on tournament which the exclusion of
some players and with the addition of
Joseph Henry Blackburn and Isadora
Ginsburg and it's a bit of a different
tournament first all of them will play a
single round-robin and then five of the
players who do best in this first part
of the tournament the single round-robin
will then proceed into the second part
of the tournament which will be a double
round-robin so five of the players who
do best and then play a double
round-robin and then we see who the true
champion is and you know the favorites
definitely imagine Alaska world champion
josé raúl capablanca and Akiba
Rubinstein and those who have proven
themselves so far but you know it's a
new tournament anything can happen and
yeah like we mentioned during the
negotiations with last Kirkup of longer
had a lot of exhibitions
he traveled you know a lot played a lot
of games and has covered a lot of games
but it would be too much to show all of
them so I decided which games to show
which games not to show and yeah here we
have a very nice game between arrow
names of which who you know has
protested against a couple monka playing
in the 1911 tournament of San Sebastian
as he did not win any major tournament
so far then couple Blanca beat him which
the black pieces here is names a chance
for a revenge and we'll see how it goes
but before we check that out and we do
have a nice photo
not just of all the players of the 1914
sankt-petersburg tournament but also
some of the players who we cannot
identify here if we push the photo up a
bit then we can see we even have some
names here not all of the names are
familiar for for example the first
person standing I cannot recognize
either the name or the person but then
you know the second person standing
Frank James Marshall then we have third
person standing Alexander yen then
nimzowitsch for some reason not staring
at the camera but sideways then a couple
of people we cannot recognize them as
Moscow borovsky and also the last
gentleman standing on the right we
cannot recognize but then sitting from
bottom left we have Easter Ginsburg
joseph henry blackburn then third
sitting we have a dr. emmanuel asker
world champion then we have Tara burn
then gentlemen who we cannot recognize I
believe the elderly gentleman with the
beard then next to him very recognizable
Akiba Rubenstein then to the right of
Rubenstein we have Jose rule kappa
blanka and to the right of Capablanca
jaan offski so an excellent photo I do
hope you enjoyed that as well and also I
found this very nice photo it's actually
a very nice high quality photo there we
have it
Lasker a lake in Capablanca Frank James
Marshall and Ziegler tirage either all
analyzing some position or alien
Capablanca and Marshall are you know
just keep it single game played between
dr. Emmanuel Alaska and the zig Bert
Irish so I hope you enjoyed there as
well but I will put a link in the
description below to where you can check
out these two photos and a lot more
other photos from the 1914 tournament of
some picture books so I hope you enjoyed
that as well without further ado
okay just one more thing I did find in a
book by Edward winter about Capablanca
ah just two sentences a couple of
markers opinion of Paul Morphy which I
never anywhere read on the internet so I
I thought you might enjoy that as well
so I'll just read it to you so I don't
get anything wrong
so Capablanca says the Magnificent
American master had the most
extraordinary brain then anybody has
ever had for chess technique strategy
tactics knowledge which is
conceivable for us all that was
possessed by morphe 54 years ago one
example in his time theoretical
knowledge of the openings did not exist
so to speak yet what more if he played
56 years ago against the Petrov defense
it's considered today by Lasker and me
to be the strongest continuation for
white so as you can see Capablanca held
morphe in the highest regard I just
thought you might enjoy that little part
as well Albert okay we're gonna talk a
lot more about this tournament as the
game's progress as well as just dive
straight into this one names of each
like in the 1911 tournament of San
Sebastian opens with E for we have e5
Knight f3 Knight to c6 and now Knight to
c3 the three Knights opening Knight to
f6 we have the four Knights game but we
will transpose into the rule opus either
way so not really not really much of a
difference there should be 5 b6 and now
d4 we have Bishop captures sorry first
Bishop d7 then Bishop captures Bishop
captures and now we are in the
individual opus d4 pawn is under attack
and we have Queen to d3 my name is Erick
you could try D 5 but then Capablanca
can just shifted the bishop over to g4
and you can always undermine the central
later we are c6 so it's not not that
great of a move after Bishop to c6 we
have Queen d3 defending d4 pawn and now
II characters on d4 Knight captures on
d4 and now kappa blanka says that okay
in the previous games that were played
that Bishop d7 is the idea but
Capablanca had an idea over the board
here a sort of a inspiration in the
moment and he played g6 he he I was an
image to capture and c6 here double up
his pawns and even even a relinquish
polka Blanca of the bishop pair but he
ran him so which has two options
Bishop g5 is one of them simply
attacking the knight here pinning at
Bishop g7 going for queenside castle and
if Capablanca decides to go for a king
sized castle denhams which would have a
very sharp key a game and a very strong
attack on the Kings side but names of it
sure decides this character will have a
this game will have a different
character he after this g6 move captures
on c6
we have B captures and now immediately
go
Queen to a6 he will use this maneuver of
attacking the undefended pawn and c6
after a couple Blanca defends it with
Queen d7 now he goes here defends the
rook and now you cannot to go back with
the Queen as the c6 pawn will remain
undefended so we have roped the c8 and
now Queen characters on a7 name so he
decides this is the way he wants to go
he grabs a pawn and now creates a past a
pawn but capablanca will be somewhat
ahead in development and this was a very
very modern idea it's not fully a fully
justified but Cooper Blanca thought that
as he is the quicker player and names of
which have to spend time and also names
which is not familiar with this position
he will have to dwell on it longer he a
couple Monica thought this would give
him the edge Bishop to g7 how comes
castles Capablanca also castles and now
Queen to a6 trying to get the Queen back
into the game as rook to e8 is expected
and there will be pressure against d4
pawn we have group have to eat and now
Queen back to d3 the pawn is defended
and now Capablanca says okay nimzowitsch
is up a pawn he has a past April now
that is ready to be pushed but he also
already played six moves with the Queen
and it's only moved 15 so what is
Capablanca to do with all this time we
have Quinta east six first now here
kappa blanka plans the knights to go to
d7 and to be transferred over to e5
where it will be an excellent piece and
there is there will be constant pressure
against d4 pawn so it's unlikely that
names which will ever be able to
strengthen the center with f3
we have f3 for now but now comes Knight
to d7 and now you will not be able to
push f4 as to take away D 5 square from
the night because then the knight will
just go back to f4 and the d4 pawn will
be lost
Bishop to D to hear names of which could
start pushing the a pawn immediately
which could be it could be the best
choice of action here but he wants to
develop start developing his species as
well so Bishop to d2 and now we have
Knight to e5 attacking names of its
Queen Queen to e2 and now comes Knight
to c4 pressuring the bishop but also the
B to pawn so what do you do here
you can't go something like b3 it's a
very ugly move opens up this diagonal
but not only that it loses on the spot
due to Bishop b4 check simply
controlling the e3 square and after the
King moves now hopefully Knight captures
and only after Queen captures you go
Queen to f6 there's a double attack on
the night you cannot defend the knight
further and also if you move the knight
you lose the exchange so this is game
over so you have to play rook a to be 1
and now capablanca goes Luke 2:8 and now
capablanca says that the attack has
started we have a four names oh it
starts pushing his past pawn but also
the pawn is nicely protected to by the
knight on c3 and also you can see that
capablanca can already win the pawn back
with Knight captures but couple ANCA
does not want to give up his very strong
bishop just to gain back the pawn so he
will wait with that first he gets rid of
names of his dark square bishop so his
own dark square Bishop can now you know
be on a post Queen captures on d2 and
now comes Queen to c4 with putting a lot
of pressure on the c3 Knight we have
rook F to D 1 and now comes Luke e to b8
and now there's already already the
threat of recapture son b2
for example if white plays a slow move
like h3 then you get rook captures rook
captures and now bishop comes with an
attack on the Queen and the rook Queen
has to keep an eye on the rook captures
captures and we have Queen captures here
capablanca would keep a better position
being up upon so names of which first
moves the Queen we have Queen to b3 now
this whole idea will not come with an
attack on the Queen on d2 but now we get
rook to be for putting more pressure on
the 4th rank and also now Capablanca is
ready to double up looks on the B file
Queen to g5 and now comes rush up to d4
check first King to h1 and now rook a to
b8 and now you can see that there's
really not all that much names which can
do here his position is hanging by a
thread
the night will fall this point will be
week there's the threat of capturing the
night here if you allow something like
Bishop captures on c3 then rook captures
unbe one wins a whole rook and the game
is over
and there's really not all that much you
can do if you play something like this
then you just give up a pawn at the save
your knight and after something like 92
you try to give up a night for a bishop
couple Blanca would go back you still
have to defend your knight and now you
would get win captures on a4 again this
is just a cup of longer has doubled
rooks and along the B file the this
Bishop is cutting the board in half it's
just a too too great of a position for
black Capablanca would definitely win
this position so after rook a to be 8 we
have rook to Defour here nimzowitsch
decides to give up the exchange for for
this Bishop rook captures on d4 but
there wasn't anything better as we
already show that that other position
would just be a very slow painful death
for names which Queen captures on d4 and
now comes Luke to d1 attacking the Queen
Queen goes back to c4 and now comes h4
and here a cup of lanka says that he's
winning back the pawn he's up the
exchange that any further commentary on
this game is it's pretty much pointless
as the game is winning but that's easy
for safety for Capablanca we're just
gonna show it and you know see see what
poisons names of each prepared for kappa
blanka in this later part of the game
Queen back to d2 now the knight has to
be defended as the b-pawn is born we
have Queen to c5 and now comes Luke to e
1 we have Queen to h5 a cover Blanca
immediately goes for the h4 pawn and
it's impossible to defend it if you try
this then you lose this pawn if you try
something like Queen f2 do you see the
idea now it's a very nice idea
you can even pause the video you know
just some small tactics for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent tactician and for
those who if you just wanna enjoy show
you have to overload the Queen the
opponent see to end the rook on e1 are
both guarded by the Queen so simply rook
captures on c2
after Queen captures Queen captures on
export delivers check also threatens now
undefended rook on e one King Jiwon
Queen captures King eh - and now black
can play whatever he whatever he wants
his of the exchange and you know just a
would a winning game so after this
to h5 we have looked back to a1
preparing to push the past pawn and our
cup of lanka simply grabs upon we have
Queen captures King g1 queen h5
preparing Queen c5 we have a five and
now just a Rhema nuvaring rook e8 taking
control of the a file a six and now
Queen to c5 with check King h1 now comes
Queen to c4 with a double attack on the
a6 pawn with a 7 and now Queen back to
c5 now the pond will fall and there's
nothing white can do about it
names of each plate B 5 here we have
Queen captures on e5 it doesn't matter
for the time being the a 7-point stays
alive but a couple Blanca calculates
precisely that there was enough time to
do this we have looked to a4 and now
just Rema nuvaring the Queen back to the
attack of the a7 point but with Czech
Queen h5 check King's you want and Queen
back to c5 check again the queen is in
the right spot King to h2 and now even
d5 there's plenty of time to win back
the pawn we have looked to h4 now with
some ideas of getting the Queen over to
h6 and attacking the King side but
Capablanca doesn't care he plays rook
captures on a7 and here names are simple
play Knight study 1 and it was in this
possession that our names of which are
more 42 resigned the game he resigned
because Queen captures on c2 just you
know it's game over now Queen to h6 is
impossible because of well Queen - G -
checkmate and on the other hand if you
don't play something like 91 if you play
something like Queen to h6 still doesn't
matter black has nothing to worry about
just Queen captures on c3 and it's
everything is fine you can even allow
this a few checks can go to e7 let's say
Queen g5 check now you block Queen f6
and after one more check the King
escapes and now there are no more checks
no more dangerous black is just up a
whole rook and it's it's game over
so yeah I named it after 91 resigned the
game and a couple Lanka starts the 1914
tournament of sankt-petersburg
which are very nice in victory this time
items which did not protest about
Capablanca participating s Capablanca
has won a major in turn
all tournament that is of course the
1911 tournament of San Sebastiano but
still you know he didn't get his revenge
but you know what are you gonna do sir
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you're enjoying my coverage
over the Capablanca saga so far we're
gonna talk a lot more about this
tournament as like I mentioned as the
game's progress but for the time being I
believe this is sufficient I would like
to thank Paul staples and made some
fairly support tablished society kulikov
scheme King Boo and Phillip Dennis for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thing called for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content most likely
continuing the Capablanca saga but also
as usual checking up on your suggestions
awesome thing go for watching and I will
see you soon and for the end of this
video let's check out the very nice
photo once again there you have it
mm-hmm very nice thank you all and I
will see you soon